hey I'm Greg Alva we're in positive
spirits yeah I can't wait to make a
bunch of jokes I shouldn't be in this
video cuz I've never seen 13 reasons why
and he should and we're gonna watch this
trailer and maybe it'll get him excited
to join in on the 13 reasons why so
you've seen all of it when I heard the
plot of this it's something like a
one-off can you see it continuing into a
season two I'm a little bit confused as
to what they're gonna do for season two
John said that she kills herself again
ending of the last season it could go a
lot of different ways it could be about
the like a courtroom thing still about
her thing and also there's one kid that
you see him getting some guns at the end
maybe like some sort of school shooting
could be happening I don't know where
they're gonna go with it this sounds
like my kind of show in between all my
comic book shows squeeze in some
thirteen reasons and why this is really
gonna be more of Ashley's video than
mine it's gonna be more of me going what
do you think so I'm glad you're here it
was John and I have not seen him so make
sure to follow us on Instagram check out
our YouTube channel where it's all 13
reasons why coverage
it's not
what yeah yeah I figured
[Music]
ooh
the ring
it's kind of more of a more realistic
Riverdale by we're all in this together
now
don't you know about what goes on at the
school this is proof for they all did
you doesn't always make things right
it's gonna keep happening
it doesn't stop Wow nothing happening
except justice for our daughter
[Music]
now Greg's been a lot let's get to that
guns I have to do this myself you don't
no one's gonna get justice
mmm
I didn't see anything courtroom in there
I was totally wrong so okay that's nice
so okay so based off of what I've heard
of 13 reasons why which is an unveiling
of trying to figure out why this girl
killed herself and it's cutting around
to multiple different story lines this
seems like it's gonna stray away from
that format it seems like it's gonna
just be a very linear told story of the
after-effects of now that they've
uncovered why and the effects that it's
having on the remaining characters the
after drama of it which I'm which I find
actually even more appealing than what
I've heard about the first 13 reasons
why we all know the 13 people
okay have the tapes they all know you
know so it's like now this like secret
but nobody else knows so good now it's
like keeping the secret to through the
season but there's people who are
threatening and stuff or these guys the
mystery is like because it seems like
there needs to be a new mystery to set
up and is the new mystery like who knows
this information now I guess so maybe
I'm not really sure where does it feel
like it's gonna be a different type of
show kind of a little bit well the cool
thing about the first season was that
each episode was a new tape so it would
start her tape you know and explain why
this person had basically a hand in her
taking her oh yeah like you said like
that formats gone and I thought that
that was actually really cool with her
season that it was that now it's not
gonna be there's no more like 13
episodes each tape each episode so it's
just like a [ __ ] like you said like
riverdale away yeah it feels more like a
more grounded riverdale to me like a
teen highschool murder mystery in a way
yeah yeah
and then watching the psychological
deprivation of these kids in high school
who are having a deal with the
after-effects of such a tragedy but it
sounds like the first season was about
unveiling this doesn't seem like it's
about unveiling as much as it is
watching them psychologically
deteriorated to know who's sending these
notes you know it's like I know you did
last summer yeah they're making the mint
the kid in it the main the main kid I
feel like he's like becoming more and
more like the hero through the show okay
he starts off as like this kind of
insecure kid now like he's like the
detective like he's trying to figure it
out for her like he that's why when he's
seeing her in like his dream or whatever
you know like she's there she's not
really alive but it's like up to him to
like figure this out for her or whatever
it is this mystery that's going on I'm
not as excited about the season as the
first season I mean I'll definitely
watch it for sure because I invested 13
13 reasons why sequel book expand this
[ __ ] yeah what I heard about the first
13 reasons why was it sounded like a
tough thing to sit through because of
the rawness of it this feels more like
television this seems like gonna like
push the limits as much as they did the
first season I wonder if they're toning
it down a little bit this season I kind
of hope that they don't though because
that's what made it such a phenomenon
yeah I think I'll sit through this first
season so I could watch everyone flip
out about how the second seasons ruined
the first season I have not seen 13
reasons why I just have a hard time
imagining that with the vibe I'm getting
from this which has this like Riverdale
One Tree Hill vibe up to whatever it
would have been cooler like as a
miniseries you know that's what I
thought especially because it's 13 of
them yeah and I think that they should
have just ended it but I mean we'll see
I thought that's what it was I thought
it was a one-off I think that's what it
was supposed to be yeah just the trailer
could be wrong we'll find out well
thanks for being here Ashley
because I would have had no real input
on this appreciate that do you guys
think this will actually be a worthwhile
season or does it seem like they're just
milking it put your comments down below
you guys can subscribe to the reject
nation hey click that notification bell
to get notified every time one of our
videos is up and you can check us out on
patreon because there's fun stuff there
more importantly follow Ashley n on
Instagram and also check out our YouTube
channel links in the description box you
can catch us performing live jazz music
at the El Portal Theatre in North
Hollywood see you guys there yep